هذا هو مخيم المغازي بعد انسحاب القوات
الاسرائيليه منه خلال الساعات الماضيه
باتت المنطقه عباره عن كومه من الركام حسب
ما شاهدنا في داخل المخيم وايضا في
الاطراف الشرقيه لمخيم المغازي هنا جثث
الشهداء ايضا ملقاه في الشوارع حتى هذه
اللحظات لم تتمكن سيارات الاسعاف من
الوصول اليهم لنقلهم بتجاه مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح عدد من الجثث الشهداء
باتت متحلله تماما بعد انسحاب اليهود من
المعسكر من هنا لقي الدنيا كلها كلها
مدمره لا ظلت دار ولا ظل بنادمين جثس محل
في الشوارع وما حد بطلع لنا العالم كله
ساكت ما حد بطلع ل الشعب الغلبان هذا شعب
رجعنا 100 سنه لورا احنا هنا المقبره تعرف
بمقبره الانجليز هنا في منطقه مخيم
المغازي وسط قطاع غزه لحق بها الدمار وقد
دمرتها القوات الاسرائيليه التي كانت
متوغلا في هذه المنطقه قبل ايام هو المشهد
الاساسي هنا في مخيم المغازي للاجئين
الفلسطينيين بعد انسحاب الفرقه 36 من داخل
المخيم خلال الساعات الماضيه هنا حتى جثث
الشهداء مازالت ملقى على الشوارع ولم
تستطع سيارات الاسعاف بالوصول اليهم بسبب
الدمار الكبير في البنيه التحتيه وفي
منازل المواطنين داخل المخيم اشرف ابو
عمره لقناه الجزيره مخيم المغازي وسط قطاع
غزه